30 ans ça se fête en chanson et en danse
inauguré en 1993 le Théâtre de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines incarnait une
volonté politique forte apporter la
culture à tous et 30 ans plus tard cette
volonté n'a pas changé les 50 chinois
sont bien appropriés ce théâtre
national
dont on est très fier c'est un symbole
et en plus c'est un peu le vaisseau
amiral comme on dit aussi de la culture
à Saint-Quentin mais même au-delà dans
une ville il est essentiel d'avoir des
lieux de culture comme celui-ci parce
que c'est ça qui permet d'abord d'aller
vers l'autre de créer du lien avec les
habitants et en même temps cette culture
ce que l'on apprend ce que l'on nous
donne à voir ça aussi c'est quelque
chose qui fait grandir les gens et donc
c'est essentiel dans une ville une villa
accomplie d'avoir une scène nationale et
je pense qu'on a vraiment beaucoup de
chance de l'avoir ici sur Saint-Quentin
à Montigny pour fêter ses 30 ans le
Théâtre de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines est
la médiathèque du canal ou organiser un
week-end festif
c'était aussi l'occasion pour l'équipe
de la scène nationale de partager sa
prochaine saison culturelle qui sera
composée de 60 spectacles on essaie de
se demander qu'est-ce que les publics
les spectateurs dans leur grande
diversité
pourrait aimer qu'ils ne savent pas
encore qu'ils aiment mais ça veut dire
aussi que on va la recherche de plein de
jeunes artistes et que ce lieu est pas
seulement un lieu dans lequel on vient
voir des artistes que l'on connaît mais
aussi des lieux un lieu dans lequel on
vient découvrir des artistes danse
musique cirque il y en a pour tous les
goûts je suis fidèle au théâtre de
Saint-Quentin oui pour sa programmation
diverses
pour toute catégorie confondues c'est
très novateur c'est des scènes qu'on
retrouve pas forcément dans nos
banlieues le théâtre de Saint-Quentin
propose beaucoup de danses
et c'est vrai qu'en fonction des
différentes villes les théâtres sont
plus axés sur un domaine ou l'autre donc
ça permet d'avoir un panel de
proposition je suis abonnée et je viens
très très souvent en plein de concerts
différents ce qui est l'avantage c'est
qu'il y a une programmation très
très diverses donc on peut tester plein
de choses et le Théâtre de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines se tourne vers
l'avenir en janvier 2024 il se lance
dans des travaux de rénovation avec
notamment la construction d'un café et
d'un restaurant la programmation se fera
alors à l'extérieur des murs dans une
quinzaine de lieux différents